i should be able to see something here
ah welcome to another
uh computer music
this is 11 years in a row now that i've
been given a lecture about this time of
year um
where i'm trying to tell you what i
think the coolest thing i learned about
trees was during the year
and
uh i uh
i guess my main announcement for today
is that
is that this year i finally got um
i finally finished writing
a lot of the stuff up about trees that
i've been talking about in past years uh
uh
if you can
put this on the screen
uh this is uh
now if you go to my home page and and
ask for um
wow okay i got a funny monitor here
uh if you go to my home page and and
then go to the news page and it'll it
it'll tell you how to click and get this
uh
this preprint
um and
it includes a lot of stuff that i i was
talking about like last year i talked
about how to find all spanning trees of
the graph
and uh so you know that's in here
um somewhere where are we talking
spanning trees
they were you know
here we're doing spanning trees okay
um
go back a little bit we've got
uh something called the christmas tree
pattern this is what i talked about two
years ago i think when i the title was
called chains of subsets but we decided
to call it the christmas tree pattern
uh there's uh lots of cool stuff i
haven't talked about in in class about
that you know
if you take
random trees and then you you plot where
the uh
where the nodes lie
you get this kind of a pattern
um
you know
many other
beautiful stuff about trees i talked
about lattices of trees a few years ago
i think lao remembers that one
so those are
those are here
are pictures of
different lattices of trees
and so on so uh i'm happy that at last
all this stuff i've been thinking about
for years and years i got down on paper
and it seems to be
you know seems to check out and work
and today i'm talking about
sand piles and spanning trees which is
something i learned about
just before i finished writing this
section in fact it's exercise 103 in
this
in these notes
um
and um
in fact i thought i would
find it by looking in the index just
just before the lecture today
and i see that i've omitted the world's
word sand pile from the index um
unfortunately
so i have to pay myself 256 cents but if
you find any other errors in this uh
in this
version then uh
then you can get 2.56 cents for for it
so sand pile should have said right
there on page 42. but here we are
exercise about sample
and then uh
the answer uh
coming up so so this is the this is one
of the most fantastic things like uh
it's almost unbelievable uh but it was
it was started by
uh
said about 15 years ago by a physicist
uh named
dar
um
and uh let's see
i'm just training the camera operator
here can
can you zoom up here here you see here's
how he he writes his name in hindi
so he um
started this all
and there's been lots of papers in the
physics literature about about sand pile
models
and uh but but the the curious thing is
that it works also for people like me
who who want to deal with discreet stuff
and
and uh as we'll see that uh there's a
huge number of uh
of uh
of results about
graphs and trees
that uh that relate to this physics
model of sandpaper
um now
on page 70 is the reference then to the
physics literature and so on
now
in this in the christmas spirit
i i've decided that whoever asked the
best
question
today
you haven't been responding very much to
what i'm saying here so i've got to see
if anybody's you know paying attention
but whoever asks the best question you
know
i'll give you a present
and you can either have you know these
notes which of course are free on the
web
or you can have a copy of the art of
computer programming volume one two or
three
or you can have the textbook here
or you could end up and whoever asks the
best
question and under and reads japanese
can have um
uh can have the art of computer
programming volume one in japanese
because uh they sent me four copies and
i you know and i only needed
two two of them or actually only needed
one so
so uh
uh i kept one for next year's christmas
present
all right so um
there you are i got one two three four
five six presents here
uh
you know that you can choose if you if
you ask a decent question now
yes dan
what is the question i will give you a
gift okay so we put you in the queue
right there all right now so so dan is
so far ahead of everybody
in these
things and if you lose japanese he has a
choice of 70. okay but what is this all
about sand piles well
um
it actually um
this this model applies to an arbitrary
directed graph almost arbitrary directed
graph which i think everybody knows what
directed graph is
the only condition that i'm putting on a
directed graph is that there's a
designated vertex in the graph which we
call vertex 0
and there's a path from every everybody
to vertex 0.
so the graph is not only connected it
has this you know what's called a sink
vertex so
so
this means that uh in particular uh
there's a way to make a tree
like an oriented spanning tree on the
graph this means for every
vertex except x0 or v0 i guess we call
it
we give one arc coming out of it that
that gets it closer to v zero
and then uh
and then by following these arcs we'll
eventually get to that root
so so there's at least one
uh oriented spanning tree in the graph
with the root of v zero and that's the
only condition that i put on on a
directed graph so of course there's a
there's a zillion wonderful directed
graphs that that each have different
meanings to us and
and for each one we can play the sand
pile game now i'm going to illustrate
the sandpile game on just a very simple
case which is actually a graph not a
directed graph
i'm going to consider a 3x3 taurus
just because it was it it's about the
right size for the examples that i want
to do
um
and uh
and it means that there are nine
vertices and uh we'll call them zero one
two three
four five six seven
where you stop at eight and um
and then each one is is adjacent to to
the ones next to it uh you know
horizontally and vertically and also it
wraps around that's why i call it a
torus so
so this one goes and wraps around and
comes up you know you can think of six
as being up here six seven eight as
being up here um sort of a shadow
um
effect there and uh
and similarly zero 3 and 6 are over at
the right and 0 1 and 2 at the bottom
and so on so so this is a graph which
every vertex has four
neighbors
and
it's a directed graph in the sense that
uh
each of these lines means there's a you
can go
there's an arc going to the right and an
arc going to the left
okay now um
we play the the following game
on on the directed graph
uh we put
we put pieces of sand on every vertex
except except the special vertex v0 uh
you put sand on there and um just for
the heck of it let me imagine that i put
four grains of sand on each one it can
be any number any uh
non-negative numbers
um
and
but if it was all zero we
we wouldn't have any fun because i'll
tell you what the rules of the game are
the rules of the game are if any
any vertex
i'll specialize for this particular
graph and and uh you'll see how it works
for any director of that so in this
particular graph if you have at least
four grains of sand on a vertex
then you can
you can
take four away and and distribute one to
each neighbor
so for example
this one has four so i
so i i change it to zero and i put one
on each of its neighbors
that's one goes here i i didn't list the
number of the sand this guy so
so uh
one goes here this guy now has five
um
one goes down and so this guy has five
um and one goes up so this guy has five
and um one goes to the left but there
but but that's his that's vertex v zero
so it disappears
so we lost the grain of sand there
but um
otherwise uh you know we uh
we uh okay not now
now we know we repeat this process until
we can't do it anymore
so as long as somebody has at least four
grains of sand
uh
then we can uh you know again then we do
this operation it's called toppling
toppling out of vertex and and and a
sequence of topplings is called an
avalanche
so so this is what this you know comes
from
from physics you are the question
can you know what travel to a vertex
with no sand on it
yeah
you add one to to each of the uh
of the neighbors
but but this guy i didn't write anything
there because he's he's
actually he's a whole
the sand goes down into the you know
into the inner earth and the middle
earth and disappears there yeah but now
you're ahead of that
in the in the question in in the
question competition okay but now what
do you think uh okay now i'm just going
to cycle through here and i'm going to
take the first the first guy uh i'm
sorry go go one two three four five six
seven eight one two three four five six
seven eight and keep doing this until
i've gone through uh several you know uh
eight steps in a row without making a
change uh and then i'll be stuck
so
five comes up next so what do you think
is going to be
you know
test if anybody knows the rules of this
game what's going to be the situation
after
afterwards how many is going to be on uh
you know in place of this zero here yeah
you got it
one
how much here one yeah there's one left
we take four away uh one goes to the
left one goes up one goes down one goes
to the right and disappears and so this
is going to be
four
five
and this will be four five
five okay
now um
uh once more to what to warm up and then
i'll show you the whole then then i'll
then i'll start doing it myself okay so
there's four again we're gonna lose one
it's going to go up left right down so
north south east west so this goes zero
we're going to have six we're gonna have
six coming over here
five five five
all right and uh
uh okay now now i'm at this place the
six is going to move and it's going to
leave two there in the middle and uh
okay so i get two one
one two seven
five six five and you can trust me on
this i had a computer program
do this this morning so so that i
wouldn't screw up
um so i so the next step we're changing
the seven and that gives us two two two
three three five six six
uh then we go two two three three three
177 as the five topples this first seven
is going to topple here that's giving us
a three two three four three
two three eight
eight is toppling and we're getting
three three
three four four this is getting some
nice and symmetrical three four four
now um you know this would make a
wonderful java applet to put on the uh
on the web where you could just watch
this thing toppling away
um now
before i finish uh you know or maybe i'm
going to get into a loop what do you
think is it possible to is it possible
that this could go on forever
what do you think yeah yeah
well
not each time but a lot of the times
you're losing one into when i'm losing a
grain of sand i'm certainly not getting
in the loop so yeah right so if i'm
losing a grain of salt i'm certainly
making some kind of progress to a
different state but what but but could i
possibly then go for a cycle and never
lose a grain of sand
one of your grains is always moving
towards the hole because there's always
a path to the hole that's true one is
always moving towards
upwards all right and that's the and
that's the secret uh in general
uh in general i have a directed graph
and every
vertex has a certain out degree
and and that out degree is is the number
four in this example right so so if if
you have as many grains of sand as
you're out degree then you send sand to
every one of the of the people
who you have an ark out of you that's
the that's the rule for the general
directed graph and in the general
directed graph i assume that there was a
uh that there was a path to zero from
everybody that means that i can arrange
the vertices into into an order so that
everybody has
an arc coming out that goes to a lower
numbered vertex
are all the arcs here by direction
these are bi-directionally in the taurus
but but in the general case
not not every theorem i'm going to talk
about today works for every directed
graph
i'll tell you what the restrictions are
but but but most of the most of the
things work for every directed graph
that has at least one
oriented subtree uh
with the root zero
so so this is uh uh
uh
so
so the point is though that if
every everybody in in the directed case
is gonna have at least one neighbor
that's that's lower numbered that means
that if you don't lose any sand
then you're always increasing in
lexicographic order you're always
increasing the the the the uh state
where we list the number the pieces of
sand on each on each one and so you
can't increase an increase indefinitely
and so you can't have a cycle so so the
uh
now i have a lot of
visitors probably some of you can speak
to japanese i have to tell you the
people who came in um
there's a prize offered
to the people person who asked the best
question like you know
like
what like why did
why didn't you wait for me uh
and
and and especially the one who asked the
best question and reads japanese can
have the art of computer programming in
japanese
okay now um
so as i'm saying uh
eventually we're going to get to a
stable state and it's stable means that
there aren't any
any tacklings
left anymore that means that every
vertex
in this case has four uh has has three
or less
guys yeah
then you can't topple
do you skip it
uh right now i'm skipping it yeah so i'm
so i yeah now there
that's my next question what happens if
i took another algorithm for for this
instead of going through you know
one two three four five seven eight what
if i
what if i use some other like like i've
got uh where's this four ones i had this
eight here you know maybe i should have
you know maybe i could
could you know double topple from the
eight and send two guys out you know i
didn't do that
i only went to four here
uh okay but anyway i got four i'm i'm
still toppling away here and for the
people who just walked in see if you can
guess the rule that i'm using
but what i did is i took the six grains
of sand here and i sent one up one to
the left one down and one to the right
but down
it came back in at the top so this four
went up to a five and going to the right
change this four to a five so now i got
five two two
um
uh
one six
five three two i'm toppling um
now this five um the first five there
and then i toppled is six and that gives
me two two five three three five three
three
um
now pretty soon we're going to see that
we're
actually in um
well i i guess this is getting kind of
boring now so i'll show you just see if
you can read it off of my golf of my
notes the cheat sheet here so if we got
here and i finally got to this state see
this one three three three two two three
two two so on and on and on it gets to
three three
trust me uh
three two two three two two and the
total number of steps was one two three
four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen twenty three twenty
four two five two six twenty seven after
twenty eight steps here we are yep
that is the that is an excellent
question and that is what i wanted
somebody to ask so so you're you're
you're way ahead now so so now uh
that's the question what if i did the
top link in a different order okay and
so the first theorem is it doesn't
matter you always get this same final
state no matter which way you did the
top link
now how do we prove that and uh well the
in fact there's lots of theorems in
mathematics that are much harder to
prove that use the same idea yeah you've
got it right
we always get to the final state from
the
initial state so if we had started the
difference right so here's so so here's
the idea imagine that this is a state
the final state depends only on the
initial state not only or only on the
initial state not yet so so
here's some state and maybe maybe
there's six vertices that can topple
okay so i have six ways to go from here
to other states uh depending on which
one i chose to to do the top link okay
and each and these these again uh you
know my
each one might topple uh might might
have different ways of toppling and
eventual and at the end
we finally get you know stable states at
the bottom where there's no more
toppling if possible all right
imagine this big this big network we
showed that there's no infinite branches
here it eventually
it
every every branch eventually comes to
to a stable state the theorem is that
only stable states are identical
does it depend on the initial state it
depends on the initial state for sure
yeah because uh if i if the initial
state was three three three two two
three two two
that would be a the final state but if
it was three three three three three
three three three that would be the
final state
so it certainly does depend on the
initial state even
there are in fact there are how many
stable states are there in this case you
know you've got four choices at time
eight ways so that's four to the eighth
is is two to the sixteenth so that's you
know six five five three six
uh number of stable states uh that can
occur
but so for each initial state there will
be one stable state afterwards and and
and and i want to prove that
and and so what uh the way you prove it
is suppose that you have two choices um
i mean you've got more than two but but
let's suppose you had two choices um
uh so so from one state you could go
either you know either topple at vertex
10 or top left vertex 15 okay well uh
all you have to realize is that if you
uh
if you could topple it both places okay
then you could do 10 first then one of
the
the options is to come back
uh from 10 to 15 and one of the options
from 15 is to come back from 15 to 10.
and that gets you to the same
to the same one
so in many cases it's called a diamond
lemma in many in many arguments in
mathematics that if you have if you want
to show that like like the one of the
most famous things is that
is the what is it the somebody cleaning
theorem about lambda expressions but
there's many different things also in
unification here so if you can go two
ways but then you come back to the other
then it turns out these are all going to
be
all going to be identical and
the proof is that uh well
you could have done it
yeah you know if you could do first i
then j then
you know then you can always assume that
uh
that
if these operations are commutative you
can always assume that that you do it in
in your favorite order
okay so um
it's uh
uh it's true
and therefore if x is a state liao if
it's possible to do inj it may not be
possible to do j first because you may
not j may not be
unless you get something
it's okay that's okay if there's two
ways out
if you if you have two choices as to
what to do next right
then you can do them in either order and
this is the same argument that you use
when you're you know you're trying to
prove the nuthinix theorem or something
like this it's all these all these uh
arguments are the same and and in fact
what you what if you if you still aren't
convinced you know use induction on the
length of the number of topplings
and then then you see that if something
can go two ways then
you know then then this one um has the
same number of topic
you know
all outcomes of this one are equal to
this all outcomes of this one are equal
to this also therefore these are the
same therefore this is the same
yeah so
um
it's a theorem and so if you have any
state x it goes to a unique
state which are called sigma of x the
stable state that that happens with x is
your initial configuration yup i'm
getting great questions here i love this
is it true that the order of toppling
can change the number of iterations
before it reaches the final state is the
true that no what the the
sequence topping sequence can change
the number of iterations
actually this proof that i just gave
shows that it's actually also going to
be the same number of iterations
and the same number of top lines at
every vertex
um in fact that's also
going to be obvious from
another thing that certain linear
vectors are linearly independent but
okay i'm just thinking if you have um
zeros and a four and a three yep right
you'll have you'll go through one side
if you start with the three
it'll be it'll do nothing when you do
that yeah it's okay yeah you can't do
that with the three
because the three won't topple
yeah and then the next whereas if you
did it the other way you'd have the
forward trouble and then the three
there's only one candidate there's only
one candidate here
you have to start with the four in this
case
the failure of toppling does not count
as a move failure does not cause a move
in that sense
yeah other some strategies could be very
bad because they would always look at
vertex that you don't want to tackle
um
is this a result only about uh tauruses
or does this generate it's true for
every every directed graph
that has a that has an uh oriented
spanning tree
the root v1
this this and and this defines the
mapping to to to stable states so yeah
i'm presuming that the
in general the rule of this game is that
you can tackle if the number of
sandwiches is at least the outer view
of vertex
exactly yeah you never you
you you never run out of sand at any
vertex and so so if a vertex has has
five arrows going out of it uh you know
to take your favorite directed graph
it's probably got this property that you
can get from it yeah okay then then you
can play the sand pile game on it and
and you can you can keep on going and
you can write your java applet and you
can keep on going until it until it all
uh it all
percolates and at the ends you've got a
stable statement what's the complexity
of computing sigma x given x
it's
unknown
uh to me
uh
in fact we're gonna we're you know
there's gonna be a there's gonna be uh
an almost uncountable number of open
problems that are raised by
raised by this it's it's a it's a
fantastic
uh uh area to just
think about although i have to say i
don't know of any practical applications
at all
but uh you know so here i'm talking
beauty here
with given this taurus
given a stable state
add four to every non-hole vertex yeah
and run your algorithm do you get back
to that stable state no no because i
would get you see
that's not equivalent to zero if i
if i added the difference between four
and three three two
then it might happen in fact that's the
next you're you're very good you're
anticipating my next degree yeah if we
got a seven seven so so anyway i now
define what sigma of x is okay x is a
vector of
uh uh call it called a state it means
how many grains of sand do i have it you
know x in here is is an a tuple saying
how many
grains of sand are in each vertex and
and uh and we'll focus on this
particular taurus graph for now um so so
there's this function sigma of x naught
that depends on x that i just told you
about and it exists okay now let's let's
try to figure out something about
mistakes now now uh
we know how many stable states there are
it's obviously
you just take the product of the degrees
and four to the eighth in this case
but
but some of the state but now
the physics physicists are interested in
what they call recurrent states
and this means that if we it you know if
we allow nature to uh to introduce
grains of sand at random from time to
time and then that causes toppling to
occur
uh then um
some states will
will occur infinitely often but the
state like zero will never occur again
nothing ever leads to the zero state
okay so so the interesting ones are the
recurrent states the ones that the ones
that
that you can get to again
so i wrote this computer program maybe i
should put it on the web but i'll but
you can um you can take here's a program
that i
i'll probably put it on the web tonight
uh simple playing with senpai's on a
three by three taurus and then i you
know so i i explored adding one grain at
a time okay
and and then i did some more uh some
more experiments and and uh so i
so i said let's let's keep putting one
grain of let's start with all zeros
and then we put you know um
and then i'll put one grain of sand on
this vertex here so i get one zero zero
zero and then i put another on and
another on another one
and what happens and it turned out that
uh well it starts to
spread around the sand goes around and
around and
i get uh
eventually
it gets into a loop of course
and turned out to be a cycle of length
18.
so if you think oh this this is probably
a recurrent state
because you know it recurs if you keep
if if you keep on adding sand on that
one vertex uh i i'm getting these 18
things
uh well but but but still there were a
lot of states i hadn't hit yet and so i
went to one of those and i started and
again i i kept adding adding sand until
i got into a cycle i got another cycle
of a length 18. i don't know if the
cycles were all of length 18 but i kept
doing this until i started with every
possible state
and i had and i had gone until i reached
a cycle this is called so so anytime you
have a mapping that goes from x to sigma
of x uh uh this is called a functional
digraph you know it's a mapping of a set
into itself and and uh the only possible
uh and so you started at a vertex x x0
and you go to x1 x2 x3 and eventually
you know actually i i should draw it
like this because it always looks like a
six
no matter what you where you start uh
there's a certain
there's a certain tail and then
eventually you get into a loop
you take any any mapping of the finite
set into itself um and uh i so i said
okay i wonder what about all these uh
how about all this uh all of the
vertices that are in these loops now
zero zero zero isn't it it isn't in a
loop but but eventually uh it did and
this was a cycle thanks eighteen um well
there were 26 000 in some of these
vertices
however um
it turns out that the number of
recurrent states in this in this taurus
is actually 11 000 and something so that
meant there were 15 000
uh
in these loops but uh but they still
aren't recurrent in the sense that they
would they would keep occurring in
nature if we kept adding it kept on
adding sand there's only a small number
of such
of such uh
uh you know it's not really
what a recurrent
vertex is and so uh
the the real definition of recurrent and
by the way the
um
that's an error in the in the paper that
introduced this this subject in in
combinatorica in 1999
um
uh the
the paper which which inspired me to to
study it uh asserts that uh
something at the recurrent state
if
if there's
if it has the property that
that you know x is a recurrent state if
x is equal to
sigma of x plus
a for some non-negative a
that was the definition some positive a
say
the uh a is a is a vector of you know it
says you you add sand to it and you get
back to yourself again and and that was
the definition of a recurrent state but
it's but it
but it turns out that that's not the
right definition yeah
where you're
adding
grains of sand
and how
so you you add one and then you see if
you can talk if you can okay so i so
what i did was i said i i go from x
um
uh
so let's say f of x is equal to
sigma of x plus
one zero zero zero
that was my that's that's a function
so so i map
x into f of x
um
that was the experiment that i did
so i started with with a state and then
i added one grain of sand and i reduced
it i toppled and then i then that was a
that was the recurrence state and then i
go from that at another grain of sand
over and over again that's what that's
what i i was finding these these um
uh what you keep having a grand stand at
the same vertex in this experiment at
the same vertex i was always adding it
to this to vertex number one which was
this which was the first neighbor yeah
oh have you talked about the inverse of
the theta the inverse
state will have an inverse but but for
the non-recurrent state won't and and
that's that's important so
so
i got to get going uh you guys are
asking too many good questions but i
have to but a lot of the questions i can
answer by by getting on to my next
thing and that is
to figure out what are the states that
would occur infinitely often if we kept
adding sand at random to all vertices
not just to the to the first vertex and
that's not
that's fewer than the states that would
occur if we just add to the
add to a particular vertex okay now
uh so the definition that i say is a
recurrent
state um
uh x and that means that
x is equal to sigma of y
where
y1
y is you know has has um
uh
is a state which means there's y one
grains of sand on the
on on the uh
um on the first thing and all of these
numbers are are four or more
it in my example or in other words y sub
j is greater than or equal to the degree
of j the out degree of j
uh at every at every point
um
so
this this means you see that
if we if we keep adding enough sand
eventually all of these uh uh components
are going to uh
are going to get arbitrarily large and
so at some point they're at least going
to get as big as
as the degree
and as soon as uh and and it's and so
for for all of these uh
uh
you know
so let's just call it a kind of a heavy
vertex or a large one it means that
every
every vertex has at least d sub j
grains of sand on it as much sand as as
as it will topple at one
then we look at all of the
stable states that result from those
inputs
okay
not you know so
so certainly uh uh
there's a finite number of stable states
and some of them will occur from big
inputs and some of them will never occur
from big inputs so the ones that occur
from big inputs
stable states those are the ones we call
recurrent
no
it's sigma of y
for
if if there is
there exists a y for which sigma is
x is sigma of y and y is equal to is
it is is a large state
yeah uh but your definition
um
would probably
i don't know i i
i i think your definition would have to
be true uh but i'm not sure it goes one
way but not maybe not the other yeah
um
so
the definition that i believe would be
equivalent you probably prove that it's
this equivalent
is that
something is a stable state
if
for every state
there is a
state that's at least as big on all
vertices that leads to acts yeah it's a
i i know what you're what you're getting
at and that's also in my computer
program so i so so what i
for example i
i i tried now uh
also looking at what happens if you add
to vertex two
and
and you look at the cycles that you get
there
and and three and four and up to eight
and so then i took the intersection so
something was in a cycle
you know cycled by adding one cycle of
fighting two seconds
um and well then i i had um
i had seventeen thousand uh uh instead
of twenty twenty six 000 so so i still
had lots of things that weren't
recurrent states um but then but but the
actual condition is this i got in this
in this eight vertex graph the actual
condition is this you can imagine the
directed graph that has
that has uh eight colors of arcs
and and and and and put a red arc if you
if it corresponds to adding sand on
vertex one you know and put a blue arc
if it corresponds to adding center
vertex two and so you have eight colors
of arc
so then the the condition is that you
have to have one color of it one one arc
coming into you of each color
from uh from a from a recurrent vertex
and you have to have
every and you have to have at least one
everything coming out from you
uh it
okay
it the recurrent
performer said that everything coming
out stays in the set
and furthermore um
everything coming in
was in the set as well
uh uh you know you had one coming in
from of each color
it's a complicated thing but it works
but but there's much better depth
there's a much better way to test the
recurrent state yeah
and so so x is recurrent if and only if
x equals
sigma of x plus t
where t
is t is is is d minus sigma of d
okay now uh
d is the d is the state where
where everybody has
its degree
so so d is the state that has everybody
has uh you know i saw that with all
fours that was that was d
so uh example
d is equal to four four four four or you
know in my case i wrote it four four
four four four four four four four like
this and sigma of d
was the final state that came out of it
was three
3 2 2
and so t is the difference between these
notice that sigma d is always less than
d
but every component of t is positive
strictly positive
and this is one one one two two
one two two
so so in this particular in our
particular case
d is the ver is
puts four everywhere
and sig and and that reduces as we saw
uh to the to the stable
pile uh sigma d and then we subtract
that we get we get something that has um
uh that has these components now i want
to prove that
i want to prove this result and uh you
know if if the proof goes too it's not
always nice to you know prove things in
front of an audience and does anybody
get it and but it is in this uh
it isn't even those and i'm going to
prove a few things and i'm going to hand
wave a few other things but here's the
thing so suppose so i got to prove both
ways so if
x is equal to
sigma of x plus t well then it's
certainly a stable state
because it's a stable state
you know it's sigma
sigma is always something is a stable
state
then also
then x is also equal to
sigma of x plus kt for any multiple
of of t
i mean i i i i add t and i reduce and
then i add t again and i keep keep
reducing okay so there we go
now all all components of t are positive
though
and so i can make k you know big enough
so that this is the vector y that i
needed okay so
that's good now
conversely if
x equals d plus y
oh sorry sigma uh sorry x equals sigma
of y
of
uh well let me write it it's sigma of d
plus y
where where all components of of y are
non-negative okay so if if x is sigma v
plus y then it's a recurrent state
then d plus
plus y plus t
topples
to x plus t
because
we know that d plus y topples to x and i
can leave these t sitting here
but it also topples
to sigma of d
plus y plus t
because i know d tables to sigma of b
but this is equal to
d plus y
okay so therefore
sigma of x plus t
has to equal sigma d plus y
uh
you know keep toppling these until till
they get the state so these are equal
and that's what i wanted to prove
because this is x
i'm sorry this is uh
this is x
so the sigma of x plus t is equal x
right so so i now proved both both ways
of this thing so so this is a nice one
test characterization of recurrent state
um
and um and now comes the uh the
mind-boggling theorem
says that the number of recurrent states
anybody want to guess
number of recurrent states
is
the number of
oriented spanning trees rooted at g zero
or in
let's just say number of spanning trees
in the case of an a graph that
a graph an ordinary graph where we don't
have a directed graph but in general
it's the number of oriented spanning
trees with root with root zero
okay now that is the
beautiful uh
connection because you see mathematics
mathematics goes goes ahead by
showing that
two things that seem that are defined in
completely different ways actually are
you know uh are are in some sense the
same that there's a correspondence
between between
x and and y where x and y are defined
completely different intuitions
and so now um uh
this is the the fir this is the first uh
theorem
that we um
that that dar actually uh uh observed
the physicist and um well
the proof is actually um
there's the proof that he gave was
algebraic and was just just show that
there's the same number and i'll show
you how it works um but i won't go
through the details except to wave my
hands but uh what you what we do is we
we we look at the um
the so-called laplacian matrix of the of
the graph and and uh let's take uh let
me let me uh
show what the laplacian matrix looks
like in the three by three taurus
so the plastic matrix is a great is it
is a matrix where we have our one row
column for every vertex of the graph
and then in
on the diagonal we put the degree
um
and it's four
everybody has a has degree four in this
graph
three four five six seven eight and then
um
we put minus if it's if it's adjacent so
zero was the case into one two three and
six i could write minus one but i don't
have room and then zero
zero zero is everywhere else here
so vertex 1 was adjacent to 0 and 2
and
to 4 and to 7 and this one was like this
minus minus 0 0 4 minus minus
yeah it looks like this in this in this
taurus
um zero minus zero this will be zero
zero minus zero minus
zero zero this is just a this is a
two-dimensional structure to this is a
sign of a chronic or product type of
thing
um
a minus minus here minus zero zero zero
minus yeah okay this is the laplacian
um
of that guy
of the chorus
and
and the well-known matrix tree theorem
says that the determinant of
of the if you if you
toss out row zero and column zero and
take the determinant you get the number
of spanning trees
and similarly for oriented spanning
trees it also works for the number of
oriented spanning trees of anything now
that's a theorem that has lots and lots
of practical applications
um
now but you see this
you can also think of these vectors of
this matrix here
as
um as what happens under toppling
because every time i'm toppling i'm
subtracting like if i'm toppling at
vertex one i'm subtracting this
this vector from the state i'm
subtracting four
from from four grains of sand here and
i'm adding one grain at two four and
seven
all right so so so in other words
toppling at you know
toppling
at vertex i
says that x is being replaced by x minus
a sub i where a sub i is the i
uh row here
um and so um
what's happening is then that i'm i'm
looking for
the
the um
number of
of
parentheses that i can get
that
have
uh
they have all their components less than
four
um
but but i see but toppling preserves is
so so let me say that x is equivalent to
y if
if x minus y is equal to
uh you know some linear combination of
the c1a1 plus
cna and if x minus y is some linear
combination of these rows then we'll say
that those that those states are are
equivalent yeah
a positive no uh not in this definition
of equivalence okay okay so now i i'm
still not done with the with with the
theorem but the
but the but uh but but i do know that
the number of equivalence classes is the
determinant of this thing that's linear
algebra we can we can take this matrix
we can use row operations and and
triangularize it so that we have all the
entries on the diagonal our
are our integers and then the
determinant and then we get the
determinant in fact they stay positive
this is a diagonally dominant
um matrix so so we get uh we can prove
that the determinant is the number of
equivalence classes
what we want to show is that every
equivalence class contains exactly one
recurrent state
and then the number of recurrent states
equals the number of equivalence classes
okay
so um
so then the next thing is every cl
every vertex
is equivalent to a
okay is equivalent to a recurrent vertex
is equivalent to
some recurrent vertex
recurrent state
all right um
all right well uh the idea is that um
uh well
because i can triangularize this this
this matrix it's going to turn out that
x is equivalent to
x plus n times
uh
b for some vector uh
because um
uh n is the determinant of the matrix um
so so the determinant of the matrix uh
i i will be able to triangularize this
thing and then i can show that if n is
the determinant uh each one of the
entries on the diagonal is a divisor of
n and so on and so i can
show that this is true for for an
arbitrary vertex v right for our
arbitrary v i can add n you know i can
add n zero
zero
um to x and still equivalent i can add
zero n all of these things are
equivalent
so um
every class contains a recurrent state
and then
the other thing is to show that
you can't have two recurrent states that
are equivalent to each other
and that's another proof that i
that we that we uh
that that uses topic that uses toppling
in a beautiful way so let me mention it
so suppose suppose
x
is equivalent to x prime and both are
recurrent
um
states okay then what that means that x
plus
m one
a one plus
m n a n
is equal to x prime plus a prime uh
sorry m one prime a one
m n prime a n
uh for some non-negative m's this is
what this is the question that you
raised uh uh because
i can put them like i can put the
negative ones on one side and then put
the the opposite on the other side okay
and say this is equal to y
for example
now if so so so now uh x
sorry y plus kt
this t is this this special the special
number that i talked about before y plus
kt
for large large k is going to topple
uh
down to um
x plus kt
in m m1 plus m2 plus mn steps because
this vertex has so many things on it
we're going to be able
to keep on removing a1
as many times as we want to we're never
going to get to a negative
because k is so large that we've made
all the components huge
uh so so
m1
i first topple at vertex one m one times
and i top of the vertex two m two times
and so on i finally get down to x plus
k t from from y plus kt
and on the other hand it also topples to
x prime plus kt
in m1 prime plus m and prime step
uh and so now uh
therefore
therefore sigma of x plus kt equals
sigma of x prime plus kt
and this was equal to x and this is
equal to x prime by inside assumptions
so
okay i proved that i proved this uh and
and if it was too fast for you you can
always look it up so so that's a no now
this shows then uh by this by this long
thing that the number of recurrent
states exactly corresponds to the number
of trees yep
exactly exactly isn't that the question
network that you would like to to
answer and so uh in fact uh some people
did
find a find such a thing and i believe
the first one were the first people was
uh okay it was
somebody named marino lopez
um
in it called uh
approved in the annals of combinatorics
in 1997
that this that there was a uh
that there was a uh uh
uh
no i'm sorry it wasn't the one to one
correspondence the explicit
um
an explicit
one-to-one correspondence was found by
somebody but it wasn't very but it was
very complicated and it wasn't
um
and it didn't have the property
other properties that people wanted so
um however uh
last year this paper was published
um
brian can you get yeah you found it very
good for you uh the sandpar model and
cut polynomials it's in advances in
applied mathematics uh by robert
robert corey he's the one who wrote the
first paper about showing
tying it in nicely with with graphs
and one of his colleagues at
in bordeaux
and
it's it's curious that
that he happened to be looking at the uh
at the internet at my home page a day
after i announced this this this lecture
he said don did you know that i have
this nice uh
one-to-one correspondence about sand
piles and uh and i said well how on
earth did you you know did you ever find
find i just i just put
i just put a couple of sentences on my
website and he said well just
serendipity
so there so so uh uh
i learned about this paper and um
and in fact it's i i've got another way
to present his his his correspondence
which which i think is is uh
is is great and i want to show it to you
uh because i think it's really
interesting so
here so here's the that's the question
is that we would like to say
here's a recurrent state what spanning
tree does it correspond to and and and
and
for every spanning tree let's get you
know give me a recurrent state give me
give me the recurrent state so that i
could do it
and now the reason is that
as i said in mathematics we like to have
correspondences between things in one
domain and things in another domain now
already in corey's original paper he he
uh he showed this uh
uh
for for some special cases for example
the complete graph
uh he showed that the the number of
spanning trees in the complete graph is
known to be you know and uh
according to this
uh notation it's you know n
minus one to the n plus one if there are
n plus one vertices
um
uh
and and uh he found that
he he he found that
it was easy to to get a correspondence
between every recurrent state in the
complete graph and what we call parking
sequences which arise in the theory of
hashing and it was known that the number
of parking sequences was equal to the
number of spanning trees and then
there's another correspondence that
takes parking sequences into spanning
trees
well um
he also took cases like like like wheels
if people
studied concrete mathematics we have a
section there talk about the spanning
trees of fans and and the fibonacci
numbers come up in there and then uh and
the number of spanning trees related to
fibonacci numbers and
he had a fibonacci like construction
that corresponded to uh
that that showed how
you also got the recurrent thing but it
was it was a complicated thing now we've
got this beautiful new
fairly new construction
um
and um
uh i i want to present that in the next
few minutes okay we haven't got too much
time but uh so i was going to ask for
the audience to suggest a spanning tree
but now i'm going to give you a can
spanning tree in advance so let's take
this
let's take our three by three taurus
and um
and i want to to take us
an example of a spanning tree on it but
i don't want it to be an obvious
scan tree uh i wanted to show you know
to show some of what goes on so
um
uh
i'm going to say that um remember that
that that this
wraps around so i'm going to have an arc
going
from this guy up to to here
uh so so that's one connection from
vertex zero and also one coming down to
three
now um
now from from this guy i'm going to go
over here and come in this way and
that's going to get over to vertex 8
over here let's put the numbers on here
again 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
i'm going to have the numbers
this pen is getting very dull but i can
continue um and then from eight um let's
go up
to five and five can get over to four
into seven and down to one
and five maybe up to two so so this is
uh
this is one spanning tree on the on the
graph uh
it it has eight arcs um
and we can get from zero to anywhere
and uh but it but if we if if we want to
you know draw it down
uh like this uh you know imagine that
the
that the the taurus is a tile and we can
we
repeat it then then this then we're
actually getting the spanning tree looks
like this uh except that uh except that
you know that they were getting
different pieces of it uh
on the same tile
be with me but anyway that's a spanning
tree and i wanted to take one that was
that was uh you know not too obvious so
we can see that we have a taurus now the
question is find a recurrent state that
corresponds to the spanning tree
and uh
uh so
here's the algorithm watch i'm going to
just play through the algorithm and and
that should give the intuition um so so
i i i list all the arcs of the graph
first i you know 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 6 then
there's 1 goes to 0 1 2
1 4 one seven uh two i'm going to have
to list these all unfortunately two
zero two one
two five two eight
three
goes to zero three goes to four three
goes to five three goes to six
four has four things five
six seven eight okay try to
try to go uh
fast but i want okay four goes to three
1 3
5 and 7
5 goes to 2
4 and 8
6 goes to
three
zero three
seven and eight
seven goes to one
four six and eight and finally eight
goes to
two uh five and six and seven okay okay
list them all um
in general
we have we have a directed graph the
theorem uh isn't going to work exactly
uh as it does for for undirected graphs
but um
but we still want to list all the uh all
the arcs in some order
um
now
so that's
now i start out and i
and i um
ask
about the spanning tree uh so i'm gonna
have a big branching process going here
and i'm first gonna ask the question
is
uh and and and uh i have a working set
of of
vertices that i've
that i've sort of uh done with and
initially the working set is just zero
um
so
uh so so i look at a um an arc from
from one of the vertices that i've
already covered to to another one and i
take the smallest
such arc so these are all
uh all these arcs are listed in in like
graphic order here so let's take the
smallest
um
in fact uh well
like these could be weights and then
then we would it it turns out it uh
it relates to the minimum spanning tree
if we took the if we took the arcs in
order of weight but i'm going to i'm
going to use lex
correct recorder here so
for this order uh i asked the question
is zero one um
uh in the spanning tree
and the answer is no
okay
um now on
uh in my uh diagram here i'm gonna go to
the right if the answer is no
and and to the left if the answer is yes
uh
and if it's not that means then that i'm
not dealing with this arc okay now
um
uh next question then what's the next
one
0-2 is 0-2 in the spanning tree that's
not in there either so again the answer
is no
but zero three is zero three in spank
tree and the answer is yes so now what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna set
x well i'm not gonna write the y's and
n's anymore i'm gonna set x
three
two three
and
this is going to be my recurrent state
i'm going to be building it up here and
i'm going to put a 3 in this position
now why did i put a 3 there well
because three is now a known vertex
originally only zero was was known
and there are still
um
uh okay zero three uh by the way i i
have to cross out zero three there are
still three things coming out of
of it
and and that's that's where i get the
number three so when i when i add a new
vertex to my set i'm going to see how
many things haven't been crossed off and
it's
coming out of it and that's going to be
the the value that i assign here
so you watch the watch me play through
the algorithm and you pretty soon you'll
see what's going on
so my next question is
take of all the i have known vertices 0
and 3
and the things coming out of them
uh the arc's coming out the smallest one
is zero six
yep
two zero exactly uh very good and three
zero yeah okay i gotta cross off every
time i cross off one guy after class i
thought right so zero six is zero six
part of my tree the answer yes
okay so zero six is is part of the tree
so that means i'm gonna set x6
and forget to click oh there's going to
be a question mark here but i don't have
time to write the question mark so i'm
going to say x6 2 the number of things
left is that so x6 also gets set to 3
here
um
okay now uh from 0 3 and 6 leading to
other vertices what have i got
3 4 is the next next guy to ask about
so 3 4 is 3 4 in the tree no
3 4 is not there so cross it off
uh four three
goes away
uh
what what's next three five
uh three five isn't there either
so it goes out
um
uh next is uh
three six
three six okay
what
it's a new phenomenon
it's a new phenomenon three six is not
to a new new vertex that's true um
and neither is six three so really i'm
i'm asking for six seven here
what
yeah i i
i this isn't too new this doesn't go to
a new guy that's that's a good point so
six seven is the one that i asked about
and uh
again six seven is not there what's next
six
eight um
and uh 6 8 is there so i said x8
okay so 6 7 i had to cross out 6 7 6. i
had to cross out 3 5 and 5 3 yeah okay
hope i'm doing this right x8 is now
being set to
um
three
lots of threes
um
okay um
eight two
is the next thing and uh the answer is
no
so 8 2 and 2 8 aren't there
because 6 8 wasn't leading to a new
vertex you see so 6 8
well 8 5
is the next question asked
and x 8 5 gets a positive answer
and uh i'm at the bottom of my sheet
here but x5
is going to be set now
to
2.
um
so i'll put a 2 in here
and um
it will continue in this way and yup
the things that you're writing down on
the left-hand
column you're processing them in a q
order
these this here yeah this is these are
my known vertices right then i'm looking
so i've got sort of known vertices and
then then these are these are leaking
out to unknown vertices
all the arcs that that go from known to
unknown i i'm choosing always the
smallest
okay so i've done it by hand but i think
but i think i'm choosing the smallest so
so i have some
somebody told me an ordering of the arcs
and in fact any ordering is going to
work
um but i chose here alphabetic ordering
but but any ordering would work but i
have some ordering
which makes this a deterministic problem
earlier in the ordering what you just
mean earlier in the artery when you say
smallest uh this i i mean that of all
the arcs that are coming here there's
some the one that's earliest in the
ordering yes
yeah okay if the arcs were all weighted
in some way uh it would be the one that
that that least weight or the greatest
weight whichever way you want to
so
at this point when you add vertex
when you add some vertex to that list
yeah if there are edges that are coming
out of that vertex that are lower in the
order you immediately start considering
those
yes
indeed um
uh that's
that happens actually after five here
i start
checking five two and then i check two
one and it turns out so i won't i won't
continue with five after i after i bring
five into i'm gonna try i'm gonna ask
for two one before i look for all the
fives so every year on the vertices just
like a
correspondence between spanning trees
and
and uh recurrent states say that again
every
so i'm not getting only one window in
correspondence i'm getting one for every
every ordering of the edges which means
for example for every weighting of the
of the
edges like like in the minimum spanning
tree algorithm we always choose the uh
the first edge that comes out
so so if if i if i had the minimum
spanning tree
and if my edges were ordered by by
weight
then i would always take the yes branch
and if the graph is a directed ground
but it happens to have an edge from x to
y and y to x they could have the
directed graph let me bring up later
because the directed graph is
complicated
um
uh but okay so i i haven't kind of play
out the whole
the whole thing if you if you do it
yourself you you would you would find
out that the that that you that you fill
in x 5 equals 2 and then you fill in x 2
equals 1
and then
x 4 is 2 and then x7 is 2 and finally x1
is set to 0.
and this turns out to be a recurrent
state
that corresponds to this bank tree that
i gave
now
um
another theorem
uh
which i will state but i won't prove
in a graph uh in a balanced directed
graph
uh or uh in particular
this means that in degree and out degree
are the same at every vertex so in
particular for an undirected graph it's
always balanced
uh then x is recurrent
if and only if x equals
sigma of x plus a
where a is equal to the
um
the uh neighbors of
of of v zero
um in in the um in the matrix that i
that i wrote down here a is is the
negative of this um of this top row here
so so in my case it's the neighbors of v
0 this is a
so
so not only is it for x sigma of x plus
t where t was this fairly large thing
with lots of lots of positive come from
it's also holds for x x plus a
and um well the reason is basically that
a is equal to a 1 plus a 2 plus a n
because the determinant because
of the form of this matrix you add up
all the rows and you get zero
of and so
this so so the sum of of these guys is
actually is the negative of the top of
the top row and so you're sort of adding
zero to that
and now um the proof in the literature
was uh
uh was faulty uh
of this theorem and uh so i wrote to
email to to corey on
saturday and he confirmed you know and
and showed in my five line proof that's
in the that's in the handout here i mean
in the in the in the book and he's he
agreed that there was a bug in his paper
and that he can't think of any shorter
proof right now than of this thing but
it's true
so
um
so uh
now
if i have a recurrent
sequence then take for example okay if i
if i have a recurrent state
uh
now i want to find the corresponding um
spanning tree and what i do is
i ask
first i ask if x1 is equal to 3
is my first question
and the answer will be yes or no and and
the
the point is this is going to correspond
exactly to my previous uh
to my previous method
because
my first question this one is is the is
zero one
um an edge of the spanning tree
and and if and the answer was no uh so
that meant that uh next time around i
would ask for something coming into one
one was not going to have three
guys left
so so so if x1
if i take this if i took the left branch
i was going to set x1 equal to 3.
but if but if i took the right branch
somewhere along the line x1 is going to
be set and it's going to and the next
time x1 has a chance to be said it's
going to be 2 the next time it's going
to be 1 and the next time it's going to
be 0. so
i'm going to branch and say is x one
equal to three and the answer is no and
i'm gonna ask is x two equal to three
and again the answer is no and x three
equal three
and here the answer is is yes
yeah um and so at this point i'll say oh
zero three was in the
uh it was in the spanning tree
and um
uh
uh and
um
if i add
if i add this vector a to you know you
know so add
add the vector 0 add the vector a to it
and you get
2 a 1 2 four two two
four two three
um
and
well i'll topple this four
uh and so this will now topple and we'll
get
one two three three five two three
uh and zero here
um
and my next question
um is going to be x6 is x6
equals
r3
and the answer is yes so i put 0 6 in
the in the thing
and i'll topple at vertex 6.
two three four
um and what's going to happen is that is
that
the
the algorithm asking about asking about
uh the values of these recurrent things
is going to exactly parallel the the
algorithm that that built before so i'll
be able to reconstruct the tree that i
had
um and you have to play with this
by yourself but it's but it's it's very
beautiful the way it all fits together
so so this gives
this uh
gives a
very nice intuitive
uh correspondence you know we can we can
psych out the way the way it's working
we can see that that looks like a lot of
graph algorithms that we play with on
spanning trees all the time uh because a
lot of explanatory algorithms you know
you start from known vertices and then
you look at the
at the arcs to the other ones and as i'm
going through here i can figure out what
are the known vertices
and i can then um that and and if the
next uh
arc that i'm going to ask about in this
part was 6 to 7 in this case i'll say is
x7 equals and then i just uh
take the next lower number
that i haven't ruled out before in
previous branches
and that will be the
converse algorithm and get me back the
spanning tree that corresponded to the
recurrent state
so that's the correspondence and carb
happens now what about so so
consequences of it i brought some
pictures here
and one of the
one of the um
uh
the the crazy things you see is that
sand piles you can add two sand piles
together
so so so if x is a recurrent
configuration if x and y are recurrent
configurations then x plus y we can say
is equal to
sigma of x plus y
this is an associative
community of operations we have an
obedient group we have we can add sand
piles together
there's got to be a zero sand pile
there's going to be you know there's
going to be our uh
sand piles are going to have certain
additive order
um
we know the structure of obedient groups
but
in particular there's a particular re
there's a unique recurrent state z which
corresponds to zero under
addition all right
so so
and uh in this part in it it turned out
that um
that
okay so
under
the theory of recurrent states
allows us to define this this
operation of addition on the states and
therefore
we now have an addition on spanning
trees the sum of two spanning trees and
some spanning trees you know there's a
spanning tree that somehow represents
zero
under a particular ordering of the of
the thing now this is to me is mind
boggling i have no idea how to intuit
this what's what's gonna mean and there
are zillions of interesting graphs in
the world uh you know you think of
you
think of planar graphs think of
of uh you know
grid graphs taurus graphs
complete graphs
cycles uh diet you know all kind of
product of grass
series paragraphs
um your favorite class of graphs each
one has uh
uh
you know
a way to
the spanning trees uh as
sand piles and then to add spanning
trees together and uh who knows if this
is going to lead to some great
applications
until we play with it and find out you
know and get more experience with these
things
okay in in a finite abelian group
you always have to have having
you always have a unique element of zero
so
this is you see um
you have uh inverses as well
i mean it's not it's not just
commutative model it you have if x plus
y equals x plus z then y equals z
yeah that's the cancellation law but you
also have
uh you also have a zero
in fact that i guess
t is it you know
uh you know z anyway
one way to get it is z you can take it
as for example 2d minus
sigma of 2d
and then reduce that
2d
is it has large components and then we
subtract off
sigma 2d
and then um and that this is equivalent
to zero and then the reduction of that
is a recurrent state so anyway
that's one way to compute z for sure
i
uh by the way i found in every case i
tried z was a multiple of a
but i haven't proved that that that's
true
are there
any orderings in which the
z you get is somehow intuitive
well first of all the z is unique
z occurs
you know where z is a sand pile
it doesn't depend on an ordering so so i
tried the different toruses here
um in fact the first one i tried was the
three by three taurus which which we
have here it has only threes and twos in
it the the white means the the the uh i
i um
just take the center of this picture
because i'm repeating that imagine i'm
repeating it over and over on the plane
of three by three uh tiles uh and then
the next one i tried was seven by seven
and i had this one
right and i started to think oh man this
starts to look like the recent election
again i had only threes and twos
um
but then i you know this was the six by
six the five by five so so here blue is
uh three
and a red is two and uh
um
yellow is one
no wait and green is uh
green is one and yellow is zero
so here's here are some green ones
coming in in the eight by eight nine by
nine had had no yellows this was a ten
by ten is this not dependent on the
choice of ordering so this doesn't
depend on this is the this is the zero
sand pile for a small taurus okay it's
it's uniquely defined as the one that's
in the equivalence class containing zero
this is the recurrent state
um and so i wasn't able to psych out
anything uh in any pattern i mean it's
it's easy to see that the
that the neighbors of
of v zero have to all be blue but other
than that that um
i i didn't i i was hoping of course that
this would be a pattern that i could you
know i could extrapolate to infinity
then i tried squares instead of instead
of wrap around i you know i said small
squares what what kind of uh
what are the zero sand piles there
and they
you know so it doesn't it
unfortunately you know
it just you know i i put the hole in the
middle too
uh here i have a you know like a 15 by
15 uh square grid uh and v zero is the
middle vertex um
there and it just you know has eightfold
symmetry but it doesn't give you any
pattern that's any it's just like
looking through a kaleidoscope you know
it looks kind of nice because it's
symmetric but i didn't see anything else
to to commend it so maybe uh uh so so
you know there's lots of open questions
here the answers to some of them might
have terrific applications some of them
you know might just be interesting some
of them might just be weird and you know
there's there's no there's no good
mathematics but but but you know we know
that for example in the in the complete
graph case uh the zero send pile is
everything uh has the maximum like all
blue corresponding on the if complete
vert complete thing with uh with n
vertices n plus one vertices the
complete graph uh the zero state is easy
to see it's just put n minus one on
every every i'm sorry n on every order
and
on every n minus one on every on
everything um and similarly for uh
probably there's something
that you can do with uh series parallel
graphs and things like that but i don't
see any pattern for these taurus and
grid graphs at the moment
okay well it's getting to be six o'clock
so um i covered pretty much what i
wanted to say except for a couple of
really
surprising things
um
uh okay i i
i said first of all that there's this
mind-boggling connection
that is even
now not only
now we have to have a have a connection
between trees and um
sand pile
and so that means we can add trees
together now this connection depends on
the ordering of the arts
but still that's not such a weird idea
because uh
when we study minimum spanning trees
when we study metroid theory we usually
order the at the the edges of the
metroid or the elements of the metroid
we usually order
things when we have a lot of algorithms
with trees so uh and
a correspondence depending on order is
no big deal and in fact the minimum
spanning tree is exactly the one that
has
every vertex has d
j minus
one
grains of sand on vertex j the degree
minus one
because that's the yes branch all the
way through that's where we find a
minimum spanning tree
but
what's the zero uh spanning tree that i
i haven't got any any handle on at all
furthermore this one one correspondence
i described it it only worked for
graphs not for directed graphs with the
directed graphs it's very it's very
interesting and as far as i know it
works only for the for the balanced
directed graphs a balanced directed
graph means eulerian graph it means that
every vertex has as many things coming
out of it as coming in
but um but it's but they can go in
in strange ways but
you have to have as many going out as
coming in
now
in but but the funny thing is you you
you try to generalize corey's uh
uh
one to one correspondence for directed
graphs and it works a very funny way it
gives you a one-to-one correspondence
between recurrent states
of recurrent states and
out-trees
uh from
from v naught
now
um i told you what an oriented spanning
tree was it says that that every vertex
has one
except v naught has has a branch coming
out that goes toward v naught and and
that and that's that means that uh
that
that's an entry into v naught
but an out tree is one where every
vertex other than v naught has something
coming
from being hot and so that that that
means
that v naught to that one now in a
balanced
digraph um
if you have a source it has also a sink
and
the
the um uh but but
this this uh method that i gave you here
this branching method uh actually it it
doesn't give you a connection between
recurrent states and entries
but without trees however
and it's something i never realized
before i studied this problem the number
of out trees in a directed gra in a
balanced graph is is the same as the
number of entries
it's uh because the determinant of the
transpose of a matrix is that is is the
same
so when you when you have a balanced
graph uh imagine that you have an
arbitrary matrix here but i put on the
on the diagonal i put the the out degree
of every vertex and then i but now it's
not a symmetrical matrix anymore because
it cut but it but every everybody has
uh as many things coming in as as going
out so the sum of the rows is still zero
um but the matrix isn't symmetrical
anymore
um but the but the number of out trees
is the determinant of the transpose of
this matrix
because the diagonal stays the same and
the other thing so so uh i never
realized before but nobody has ever as
far as i know found a one-to-one
correspondence between out trees and
entries in a in a balanced directed
graph
um
maybe there's one out there in
literature and that would be you know
very interesting to me and uh i'm i'm
tomorrow i'm leaving for europe and i'm
going to spend
three months and i'm going to be in
sweden with some of the best
commentaries in the world and we're
going to i'm i'm certainly i'm going to
see if any of them can figure out
you know how to do more with these ideas
and one of the uh things that i think is
is not obvious is to find out a good way
to one-to-one correspondence between all
out trees from the vertex and i'm not
increasing but but this uh
this one-to-one correspondence is is
funny because it gives you the obvious
um okay
and
now i think that was the main
thing i wanted to mention then oh the
the other part is then that
if you don't have a balanced digraph the
theorem is still true that the number of
recurrent states is the number of
of um oriented spanning trees but there
um
i have no idea what kind of a one-to-one
correspondence could exist and i tried
the
and i tried um
the simple graph with with three
vertices but any number of arcs going
going between them
uh you have multiple arcs it doesn't
matter
in this in this definition
everything works fine if you have two
arcs going between between vertices and
then you just pass two grains of sand
each time you topple
um
and
so in the three vertex case you can
um
you know the theorem is still true that
the number of recurrent states is is the
number of spanning trees but uh i looked
at uh
uh
the he tried to find the correspondence
and it just
baffled me even though i'm
working on a very small simple simple
problem with only a few parameters
um
so
there oh yeah one more one more nice
idea um and that is
if something's if you have a
if you look at all the recurrent states
it
they also form what's called an order
ideal means that
they're closed under
uh
okay no that if if one state is is
greater than or equal to another
if if i have a recurrent state and and i
have another one that's bigger than it
this this bigger one is obviously also
recurrent
uh because i could add another grain of
sand uh
to this
so the so so the set of recurrent states
is totally determined by the minimal
recurrent states the ones that
that you can't take away
any of their grains of sand without
being non-recurrent
so i computed all the
all the um minimal
oh yeah here's
here here we can
zoom in on this these are the these are
the are the the stable states that are
equivalent to zero there's 16 of them it
turned out in this in this particular
example
some of them were a little surprising
but they're all equivalent to zero but
only this one is recurrent
but now
if the minimal recurrence state that
like zero one zero two three three two
three is a minimal recurrent state
uh that means that uh you know
zero zero is not
you you subtract one from any of these
guys and it's no longer recurrent
and this one is also recurrent you
change the two three to a three two any
two minimal recurrent states are
non-comparable with each other um and uh
the total number of minimal recurrence
states was
1336 i don't know
uh
any good explanation for that number it
was two to the eighth two cubed times
167 or something like that um
but in the case of the complete graph
it turned the number of minimal
recurrence days turned out to be just n
factorial
so there's something about minimal
recurrence space that also deserves to
be investigated
so so character you know figure out how
to enumerate the minimum number of
minimal recurrence states for for these
samples that's another open problem and
i think
uh open problems galore if we keep uh
playing around with it you know take a
graph start playing the sample game it
raises questions then you can get some
answers for you find out oh
what's the centaur group how many uh you
know
is it a cyclic group is it
is it um
the fact you know it's got uh prime
numbers in it somehow as far as the
orders are concerned lots of uh
of the questions seem to to um
be natural for every every uh every
graph just like uh
people started applying topology to
graphs years ago and and so that led to
lots of wonderful theory so i imagine
there's a lot of stuff is ready to
bust open as people start studying this
connection with sand piles and graphs
say is that yeah all the non recurrent
state we have then we can uh
going down to the some uh specific
frequent state right yes
a non-recurrent state will eventually
lead to a return state yes then we can
group a non-recurrent state depending on
what the current state they are going to
this is right and this was the
equivalent relation that i defined i
mean
is there any rules or some mathematical
meaning or direct meaning that yeah
that's such group of uh non-recurring
states
so
i i haven't got a good idea for how to
find out exactly how to compute all of
the
elements equivalent to a
given one what i did was in my program i
took every state
and i
i just like i took all 65 000 states and
i use the union find algorithm
taking everything saying x is equivalent
to x plus a
and then uh that reduced me to uh
the right number of of equivalence
classes
um but i haven't got a good algorithm
for
uh
for solving
uh there are some good there
um i
trying to remember what's the what's the
complexity maybe dan would know of the
given a given integer matrix you know
what is the or
any integer lattice uh
uh to tell whether two vectors are equi
are equivalent to each other
wait a minute i guess this is fairly
easy because i can triangularize the
new smith normal form on the matrix and
and i could i could test whether two
things are equivalent but to test
whether they're recurrent um
is is this other test where you add x
plus a and then see if it reduces i
haven't i haven't got a good
characterization other than this
trickle-down reduction
now the there's one other thing i forgot
to mention though is that
when you when you take a recurrent state
x and you add this vector a to it this
magic vector a which is just the
neighbors of of of vertex 0.
then
it then
what happens always is that you do
exactly n
topplings every vertex topples exactly
once
and you get back to x
and the reason is you see that a is
equal i wrote down a is equal to
a 1 plus a 2 plus a n
and so x plus a is is is reducing down
to x x
and each one of these is toggling and
and these vectors are linearly
independent so there's no other way to
do so so you always have to topple
each one exactly once in order to get
down to in order to get from x plus a
down to x
um and so this is an n step process an
instep test for recurrent state
as i said i conjecture that every that
the zero vector is always a multiple of
a but i
i didn't maybe it's obvious i just
haven't seen it yet uh it was true in
every case i tried
i looked at zero vectors also on the
three by n tauruses where three was
fixed and n was was growing and i didn't
see a pattern
study these samples what kind of
questions are they interesting what when
the physics people study the examples
what kind of questions are they
interested i think they're
trying to find
questions like the uh
um
the the entropy they they're trying to
find out the the uh
uh
some kind of spin numbers about these
things or something like this they they
have certain statistics that they
calculate
um on the uh
on the states um
uh see dar observed that uh in in the
limit if we keep if we keep um adding uh
sand at random each of these recurrent
states is equally likely
i don't think he showed how fast it
converges to the limit though so this
wouldn't give us necessarily a good way
to generate a random spanning tree
but but um
that
you can anyway there's a there's
pointers to the literature in these
papers uh
and and it's easy to you know to search
on google for the different things and
look up sand pile sometimes one word
sometimes too
and
uh and but they'll they'll
they'll more
you know uh
uh be concerned about uh uh
computing and some kind of energy or
something temperature things like that
um which is you know
combinatorics
people are more interested in
you know
seeing one-to-one correspondences and in
smaller smaller examples
i don't see how i get anything
continuous out of out of this right now
lots of great questions you people are i
hope i i i need a referee to choose
who's going to get these prizes yeah
listen is there any application of this
analysis
any application of this one is
of petri nets well i bet you i bet you
there is yeah i know i i i
um
certainly uh
uh it's very much like like firing on
petrinet yeah so uh uh
that
um
i mean there's
sometimes pet yeah some people have
studied like
um an infinite
infinite number of states and and you
keep on going until
uh i mean there's no v zero um
but
but uh things sort of go out and go up
and then and then
then you only consider small
configurations instead of the recurrent
states
um
but petri nets
looks very much
like this kind of this kind of theory
doesn't it
you know
or patreon that's for the germans in the
audience
well thank you very much and now uh i i
i don't know how to decide who's going
to win the
the prize but i think uh uh i will uh
those of you who think that you deserve
it come up and then i'll choose between
you
so merry christmas to all